il est aux environs de 20 heures
lorsqu'elle est une bagarre au port du
canal de digoin les deux hommes
impliqués dans la rixe tombe à l'eau
âgés de moins de 30 ans laine donné
survit pas malgré l'arrivée rapide des
secours il meurt des suites d'un arrêt
cardio respiratoire
l'autre personne originaire de digoin
parvient à sortir seule de l'eau avant
d'être transporté à l'hôpital de
paray-le-monial
les circonstances du drame restent pour
l'instant floue pourquoi ces deux hommes
en sont ils venus aux mains
etait-il alcoolisé au moment de la
bagarre une enquête a été ouverte et
confiée à la gendarmerie de charolles
ans le deuxième homme impliqué dans la
bagarre vient de sortir de l'hôpital
il est actuellement placé en garde à vue
à la gendarmerie il y est entendu pour
des faits de violences volontaires ayant
entraîné la mort sans l'intention de la
donner
sa garde à vue pourrait durer jusqu'à 48
heures soit jusqu'à vendredi